I guess what I've always want to ask you
is shooting the section just when
Ricky's about to go out and you get shot
you can just hear the gasp in the
audience that still plays like people
are seeing it for the first time since
we have you guys here let's let's talk
about that John talk about how you
prepare them for it then like here the
actors talk about playing that well was
I just go back to Steve funny when we
get this location scout for that alley
before I'm going to shot it this guy
goes and we're looking at all this good
Ally he jumps over the fence and we're
in the hood he just saw the fence and I
think one of the clock s you guy said
don't put your head over this fish you a
white dude in this neighborhood like you
guys remember you up that fits you like
look at all this but then and then and I
that's true it's true and the fact that
Cuba Morris no stunt doubles and
everything they walked across the thing
I mean we couldn't do that now that it
was like all you gotta get doubles but I
did got [ __ ] I'm actually walking on
again we show you guys walking that's
fan those dogs were not the dogs and we
didn't have dogs after God had dog money
right that was some backyard dog's
merely dogs
so if you fail on it inside that big
that would have been your ass right so
so but I mean we didn't we didn't now I
know you're they look on your face with
you open up you weren't acting that were
you're acting it was enacted but so but
I mean I guess I guess when you're in
when you make a lot when make movies is
my first movie and you're in the zone of
working you don't really think about you
know how deep it is or house whatever
that's nervous
you just think about getting the work
done and we just got the work done that
was the day that Quincy came to set to
write um and then Quincy Jones came to
set because he was he was sussing us to
do the soundtrack which of course he's
quit every month Quincy uni he ended up
becoming an advocate for the film later
on but when the might seen my biggest
thing in that scene is not just the
sound design of it where the sound drops
out you notice the sound drops out and
you hear the kids playing in the
background and then the sound comes back
up and then you hear the kids
but when there's a great shot and I
won't belabor the point when you're
Ricky's character is dead and the car
comes up and then nobody gets out of the
car and he comes in and he holds his
brother you know he you know with Trey
on the side right and other guys are
coming in the background and they're you
know they're in the clothes background
and then the other kid Chris reg ring
comes and it I mean this is not me this
is just the actors doing it he comes in
on frame left and then audience
attention goes to that guy me and then
he drives off and just as he drives off
on the wheelchair don't boy he looks up
you know me and it's just time right you
know me and we didn't have no video
assists we didn't have no you know
saying we'd all be at because we had to
just get the shot right and for all of
you who went to make movies and
everything or do anything except one
thing I've learned from this moving the
process estimation was is all about what
people remember on film and either way
is the regression of spontaneity and so
certain times people always are like do
it again do it again you guys and actors
know what I'm talking about right and
and the big thing is to capture a
spontaneity like we didn't have any
choice but to capture some money because
we had no party any money and resources
to do what we had to do so we're there
but that's what I get out of that and so
that moment that he dies it's just a
straight a spontaneous moment you know
we had to shoot it quick it was what it
was sparse coverage and I think what
people respond to us is yes a stylistic
of it and everything in the overcranking
the slow-mo stuff but also it tucks it
their heart because they know this is
happening every day every night you know
mean throughout the country well more
specific for you because you and that's
seeing your last contact with your
brother you get into a fight with them
right which is a I mean which is just
even more horrible seeing knowing how
that the scenes going to end up you know
I wish I can say I really approached it
that way but I was really Green and John
helped me a lot obviously you know
getting me through it and talked me
through the role and everything and even
in the scene to where you know I get
shot you had the white shirt on but it
was my first time on the film
and they put you know they had to put
the squibs on my shirt and the stunt guy
came over to me he said okay now when
you're running make sure that you keep
your head up because you keep your head
down there's like many explosives going
to explode
and I was just outside oh my god I was
double alright
okay so I got a run again I get hit and
this gun it's gonna go off if I'm
looking down so whooping my load in the
face so I was just I was just so great
hurt disappoint ya know yeah it was yeah
was in his head it was all it was all it
was all in my head I remember us being a
set and everything is all time and stuff
and I like and you like come to him it
didn't do good there to go and say oh
yeah you acted you doing good you're
doing good like every time is like don't
look good and I was like dude you got it
you got you you do the bomb uh he was
always coming up and I like that same
and I really appreciate this opportunity
man because obviously it you know did
are I for me man it's all really
appreciate okay man thank you for that
once again for everybody we're talking
about the scene where Ricky gets shot
and the hub what a tough scene it is to
watch especially actually I think it's
harder to watch the second time can we
know what's coming and what are your
memories are shooting that saying you
know it's just one of those days where I
can you know I will i catering sucked
and the call was too early yeah exactly
we didn't have enough money or enough
time ever but I think one of the most
memorable things that happened to me
personally is whenever I have an
emotional scene especially earlier on in
my career I didn't know how to jump in
and out of character so I think you know
they call it method or whatever I knew I
had to be emotional I was going to lose
my best friend who was going to be shot
in my arms and bleed out in front of me
so I knew it was gonna be an emotional
day so I got out of makeup and I sat in
my trailer and I was brooded you know
got really into the thing and then as
soon as I walked in that alley and saw
that Alan I was emotional and and I
can't remember the actor's name but he
was in red and he was the one that
shoots Laura Laura white comes up to me
goes hey man how you doing I go don't
[ __ ] talk to me right now and he goes
what's wrong with you and one appears
like leave him alone
Malone oh and I was just you know in a
moment and then we did that scene and
you know Rick I and the whole thing in
the blood and uh somebody out there the
crying and everything and the one was
over I was like oh thank god hey Lord
haters don't talk to me go away what's
wrong with you man what's wrong and it
was because he didn't understand that
that's the process you can't just jump
in and out of something that happy you
know but that's what I'll never forget
that how upset he was that I snapped at
it was like that's why we're here mullah
Maya no a master class the Cuba Gooding
jr. everybody